avec nous ce soir daniel lamarre le
toujours finalement président et chef de
la direction du cirque pour soir
monsieur la barre soir alors c'est un
groupe torontois qui prend la tête du
cirque la caisse de dépôt n'investit
plus dans le ciel du soleil qu'est ce
que ça signifie
cette nouvelle étape pour le cirque se
signifie que maintenant on aura les
capitaux nécessaires pour préparer la
relance
le groupe vous avez parlé de catalyst
effectivement ils font partie d'un
groupe de quatre fonds dont également si
bam 100 points et 7,8
benefit qui a eu quatre dirige ce groupe
de banquiers et ils ont réinvesti 375
millions de dollars ce qui va leur
permettre au cirque de lancer tous ses
spectacles au cours des deux prochaines
années
vous êtes là vous rester là le cirque du
soleil reste à montréal son siège social
mais jégou nous demander pour combien de
temps monsieur lamarre parce que
l'engagement est de cinq ans mais
au-delà de cela est ce que le siège
social pourrait déménager
je serais étonné parce que ce que les
gens oublient ce n'était pas le cas avec
tpg ce n'est pas le cas présentement non
plus n'y a pas un investisseur qui va
vouloir quitter ce siège social unique
parce que c'est pas uniquement un siège
social ces du studio c'est des ateliers
de costumes telle école de cirque liés
devant nos locaux
c'est la tohu près près de nous donc la
cité des arts du cirque et une et
comment est un investisseur serait
vraiment mal avisé de quitter nos lieux
mais qatar est et à toronto
le co président du conseil et au nevada
la majorité du ca dorénavant et hors
québec ce sera quoi la sensibilité de ce
conseil à rester au québec
ben djemaa redoute un ami à moi ce fait
20 ans qu'on travaille ensemble
il a été un contributeur important de
notre succès à las vegas est venue de
nombreuses fois à montréal dans le
centre de création donc connais
l'importance que c'est à 2
meurent ici l'autre chose on parle
beaucoup du conseil d'administration
avec raison parce que ce sont les
décideurs mais la gestion quotidienne de
l'entreprise est dirigée à 95% par des
québécois des gens de chine où ils
veulent perpétuer l'adn du ciel
d'ailleurs donc vous rester en poste
vous rester en poste comme pdg
c'est temporaire c'est transitoire où
vous restez vraiment passé quel sera
votre rôle
mon rôle n'a pas changé mon rôle est le
même c'est certain que je veux favoriser
une transition on a des équipes en place
on a des gens qui éventuellement
pourront me succéder lorsque le jour
sera venu mais pour moi ce qui est
important pour terme c'est de focaliser
sur le retour des spectacles je serais
heureux le jour où les artistes seront
sur scène et où nous anciens employés
reviendrons ici au siège social
ça va prendre malheureusement car
quelques mois mais on voyait arriver
mais est-ce que vous êtes là de façon
transitoire monsieur lamarre six mois un
an
est ce que c'est ça qui se passe là non
ce qui se passe c'est que je suis commis
auprès des nouveaux propriétaires de
d'aider l'équipe en place à créer de la
valeur
et encore une fois ce qui est le plus
important pour moi c'est que j'ai une
équipe extraordinaire
je pense à des gens comme stéphane de
faire notre si fo que pense à jocelyn
côté qui s'occupe des affaires légales
les nomades publie pas l'un des gens qui
autour de moi nous ont aidés à passer à
travers cette saga
ce marathon qui finalement aujourd'hui
connaît un dénouement heureux dénouement
heureux parce qu'on vient effacer donc
l'endettement la de 900 millions de
dollars américains mais encore 3000 kwh
à 3500 personnes qui ont perdu leur
emploi
c'est quoi votre objectif est-ce que
vous souhaitez tout relancer et
réembaucher tout le monde est ce que
c'est ça la mission ce serait le but
ultime
maintenant il faut être réaliste et
savoir faire de façon graduelle et
progressive
ce qu il est très clair que c'est limité
le nombre de spectacles qu'on pourra
ouvrir en 2021
pour nous le plan d'affaires qu'on a
présenté au nouveau propriétaire
c'est un plan où on espère et on est
confiant que en 2022
on va retrouver la profitabilité et une
base de partie de nos spectacles
existants reprendront leurs activités
vous aviez évoqué avril 2021 est-ce que
c'est toujours votre objectif ça
m'apparaît un peu ambitieux aujourd'hui
ça sera conditionné comme vous le savez
par le vaccin et la distribution massive
de du du vaccin donc je pense qu'il est
plus réaliste aujourd'hui de parler de
l'été et dans certains cas de l'otan
merci monsieur lamarre bonne chance pour
la suite
merci beaucoup c'est gentil